(speaks in foreign language)
- This was the first time
I saw the rainbow flag
raised in my home country, Egypt.
(speaks in foreign language)
I knew this was going
to be a defining moment
for the LGBT community in Egypt.
I needed to know who was brave
enough to raise the flag.
But it didn't take long for me to realize
this action had serious consequences.
- [Reporter] Egyptian authorities
have arrested seven people
for allegedly holding up a
rainbow flag at a rock concert.
- I first reached out
to Ahmed when I learned
he was being tracked by the government.
His name and his face
were all over the news.
(speaks in foreign language)
Ahmed had no choice but to hide,
while the government was
encouraging the media
to highlight these arrests
to win popular support.
(speaks in foreign language)
On October 1st 2017,
I learned Ahmed was
arrested and put to jail.
(phone ringing)
(speaks in foreign language)
I decided to fly out to Canada
and take him to his first Pride.
It was important to me
that he have a chance
to raise the rainbow flag without fear.
His story made me think
about my own journey
and how I left the Middle
East when I was 18.
I was able to explore my identity
without being suppressed.
If I was still in Egypt,
I don't know if I
would've raised the flag.
He does something a lot of
others are still scared to do.
(foreign language)
(melancholy music)
(speaks in foreign language)
(fast tempo music)
Meeting Ahmed made me realize one thing.
The first time I raised the rainbow flag,
I didn't have to fight for it.
I just felt like I belonged.
When Ahmed raised the flag
that night of the concert,
he wanted to proudly exist.
Just like everyone else.
- Hey, Unsolved is on a new channel.
And now your part.
Subscribe here.
- Subscribe here.
That was my part.